[Musique]
il
dans notre émission vip aujourd'hui nous
allons parler sport et de cyclisme sur
piste à mes côtés ryan et la halle
bonjour bonjour alors on va revenir sur
votre parcours vous avez 20 ans tout
juste vous êtes né le 21 janvier 1999 à
saint martin d'hères en isère est ici
maintenant vous retrouver ici dans les
yvelines
ces sommes j'ai donc je suis né dans en
isère et j'ai débuté ma carrière là-bas
en isère
je pratique le vélo depuis l'âge de 6
ans j'ai commencé la boxe de saint
martin d'hères évidemment du coup et
puis après de fil en aiguille j'ai
évolué jusqu'au pôle de saint-etienne
régional de pôle de saint-etienne
delage a été remarqué pour ma propre
affaire participent à des épreuves sur
piste en sprint
au début j'avais décliné un peu mais
offre et après page et je vais pourquoi
pas j'ai testé j'écoute j'ai adoré c'est
le mot j'ai adoré j'adorais ça et puis
depuis bajeux plus s'installer là en
septembre 2017 et et on va dire je suis
accro à l'appui ce nom et vous êtes
yvelinois c'est ça et qu'est ce qui vous
a donné spécialement envie de faire du
site ici mais une personne en
particulier ou tout simplement c'est
votre expérience personnelle en montant
sur le vélo non après sega à
l'expérience tous nos moutons ce vélo et
puis voilà deux va surtout que je le
côtoie mais grégory baugé quelqu'un
quelques grandes sur la piste campus qui
ici avec moi donc c'est quelque chose
d'extra de de voir quelqu'un comme ça un
grand champion et évidemment d'autres
champions pour pas pour l'opacité du
même michael d'almeida
mais comme quentin lafargue et françois
pervis étaient des gens de la piste et
du coup de dû entrer ça fait toujours
plaisir
- expérience personnelle m'a donné très
envie de nous développer dans ces
disciplines
alors en 2015 vous décrocher un titre de
champion de france de vitesse est de
l'américaine
chez les cadets c'était un déclic
vraiment pour vous ouais ouais c'était
un peu un déclic mais mon premier titre
enfin mes premiers titres plus tôt du
coup sûr cette année là c'était quelque
chose ça m'a vraiment donné m'a vraiment
donné envie de creuser sur ce côté un
peu piste et voilà et la route plus en
plus je commence à dater la route pour
participer à des grands prix des
challenges sur piste et pourquoi
pourquoi la route au tout début et vous
êtes converti au cyclisme sur piste
parce que déjà je pense j'ai des
qualités pour la piste je pense on m'a
dit que j'avais des qualités pour la
piste et puis ça commençait à être
limité au niveau de la route avec mon
pourra évidemment les monter le niveau
augmente et ça devenait de plus en plus
dur est sur la piste du coup j'avais un
potentiel et ça ça aurait été dommage de
de ne pas l'utiliser du coup je me suis
orientée vers la piste pour essayer d'en
bas c'est tout de suite ça m'a plu et et
voilà j'ai continué ainsi donc vous avez
un gabarit plutôt fait pour la piste si
je comprends bien fait ça j'étais plutôt
génétiquement j'étais plutôt que pour
voir la piste que grimper des cols et
les entraîneurs vous ont conseillé
forcément de vous orienter vers la piste
c'est ça mes entraîneurs autoroute
mondiale conseiller sur la piste
évidemment les entraîneurs nationaux qui
eux aussi ont bien travaillé pour que je
n'aie pas sur la piste et son méfait
vous l'avez plutôt bien pris ou est très
très bien pris j'ai très bien pris je me
plais complètement et je vais pas nous y
dans ma discipline alors en 2016 vous
donnez champion de france de vitesse par
équipes juniors cette fois ci plus vous
décidez de vous orienter exclusivement
vers le sprint pourquoi comme je disais
juste un petit peu avant vraiment ça
commence à être les mythes sur la route
et puis j'ai mis mes j'aimais plus tant
que ça fait enfin j'ai aimé mais je
prenais plus trop j'ai plus trop de
plaisir à rouler sur route ferme
entraîner tous âges avaient en posant de
toute chose de nouveau est vrai du coup
cette porte là puisqu'ils sont ouvertes
j'ai directement saisi ma chance et ça
va très très bien plus vraiment les
entraînements puis même finalement la
discipline en fait c'est finalement
qu'on regarde de loin c'est vraiment une
très belle 6 pin kung a le sprint après
c'est impressionnant et puis on a
vraiment des bonnes sensations plus le
sprint que l'endurance du coup sur la
piste plus ce sprint qui vont durant ce
oui pourquoi
séparé mes qualités font que je suis
plutôt plutôt orienté pour être un
sprinteur que quelqu'un qui est de fait
alors depuis les débuts chez l'équipe de
france élite c'était lors d'une manche
de coupe du monde en décembre 2017
comment vous l'avez appris comment vous
avez reçu cette nouvelle batterie basse
juste avant que la sélection tombe en
entraînement c'était une éventualité
quand je suis entré au col que j'avais
des possibilités de façade coupe du
monde là j'ai réussi à gagner ma place
et derrière varois on m'a envoyé ou
renvoyés à cette coupe du monde l'a donc
j'étais pas bien montré content pour le
première année même pas ça faisait trois
mois que j'étais au pôle que mal de
faire vraiment c'est de cette course là
j'étais très content et ça m'a donné
envie de bien bosser pour l'avenir et ça
ça du coup cette année des bons
résultats pour l'avenir c'était une
surprise ou pas un peu une surprise oui
une surprise les coaches vous aviez
peut-être préparer avant oui un petit
peu préparé une surprise c'est lui enfin
même quand une tour 6 et 7 je fais
toujours quelque chose
et qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
l'équipe de france moi c'est cette
france qui a soutenu en équipe de france
on peut demander à n'importe qui dans la
rue ils sont dix est ce que pour vous et
l'équipe de france est le must de chaque
discipline c'est
ouais c'est le graal c'est on représente
la france
pour un championnat du monde c'est
quelque chose de beau est ce que vous
êtes dire un moment donné dans votre
carrière votre jeune carrière que vous
alliez aller en équipe de france
est ce que vous aviez cet espoir là
j'avoue c'est un sport à la voix ou je
ne sais pas mais j'avais vraiment
c'était en visée cet espoir de d'y être
et du coup cette sur le sprint et j'en
suis complètement con dans laquelle
niveau où vous senti cet espoir où le
ressenti un camp ithier jeunes matin
quand j'étais jeune en fait j'avais déjà
le profil de chez les jeunes en fait je
suis ronde tout de suite rentré chez les
jeunes en équipe de france quand sur une
source queen mum donc déjà j'ai j'avais
mis mon pied mais du coup on hésite
c'est encore quelque chose d'autre et
voit ça fait toujours plaisir d'y être
quelle différence justement entre tous
cette catégorie jeunes l'élite les
balles dévastés comme on dit c'est à sa
porte son nom l'élite c'est les idées
quelque chose c'est on peut pas y'a pas
mieux donc faire partir en vue de cette
élite là c'est ça fait énormément
plaisir
cette équipe de france quand vous l'avez
intégré comment ont réagi vos proches
très fier de moi très fier et voilà
aussi plaints des cvs d'appel d or et
c'est ça des sms de mes proches donc de
mes amis c'était vrai c'était une grande
satisfaction pour moi je pense toujours
soutenu justement dans votre reer
beaucoup beaucoup ma famille énormément
et on soutient depuis tout jeune j'ai pu
tout jeune je commence à vélo alors
quelques semaines plus tard pour
participer aux premiers mondiaux élite à
apeldoorn aux pays-bas
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti quand
vous étiez sur la piste à l'atmosphère
était différente peut-être là vraiment
c'est autre chose se parent de saint pal
de coupe du monde un championnat du
monde c'est pas une coupe du monde c'est
vraiment quelque chose doit de deux
forts de ce qui se prépare autour
non c'est vrai c'est vraiment quelque
chose donc j'étais très heureux déjà
donné cette sélection et puis quand le
premier championnat du monde élite pour
ma première année j'étais vraiment
satisfait de cette performance pour moi
c'était comme une performance il faut
dire et puis way en étant à la basse et
une très bonne atmosphère avec tous les
champions tout le monde qui ont rendez
vous en forme et jusqu'à ça donne envie
devrait de revenir encore plus fort pour
pas pour que tu aussi être sur le podium
quelle était votre sensation quand vous
êtes entré dans le vélodrome
ce vélodrome plein avec des cyclistes de
haut niveau bah ouais c'est tout un
petit peu impressionnant mais je suis
resté concentré sont la preuve
c'est important justement de rester
concentré dans la même lancée dans une
épreuve comme celle-là c'est très haute
je pensais même le plus important et on
n'a pas droit à l'erreur on est dans une
série nous on n'a pas de relais à la
moindre erreur on la paie cash
gc ca
tu terreur des intentions on n'est pas
dans le match notre notre adversaire
nous surprend et c'est fini donc non non
c'est vrai faut rester bien concentré
sur le tournoi et voila voila pas se
laisser dépasser par les émotions je
dirais et puis laisser faire on va dire
son sont fines goût son instinct plutôt
laissé parler son instinct et souvent ça
fait bien les choses instant vous avez
piocher un petit peu dans l'expérience
des autres coureurs qui étaient présents
avec vous oui oui évidemment ma des
anciens déjà qu'ils n'ont plus une des
pompes conseil on a fait de retour vidéo
avec les coachs on a bien bossé sur ça
donc j'ai bien pu apprendre de mes
adversaires et puis commencer à
engranger de l'expérience en visionnant
des matchs et derrière ça m'a beaucoup
beaucoup apporté pour pour la suite pour
ses premiers championnats du monde
vous prenez la 14e place en vitesse est
ce que vous étiez déçu ou plutôt
satisfait de cette performance a juste à
ma place quand j'étais à ma place j'ai
fait 15e temps du 200 m
quelque chose du genre donc non j'étais
un moment j'étais à ma place et puis
satisfait ni déçu
enfin pas cette fille très content de
mon temps déjà que j'ai fait aux 200
mètres c'était à mon record dont que
j'étais très fier de ça puis après en
huitièmes dé finale je suis tombé contre
le futur champion du monde
du coup champion du monde on dit je peux
pas je peux pas être trop déçu
finalement ça minimise la déception
peut-être ça du coup à un championnat du
monde
on va dire plutôt réussi ça vous à
booster pour la suite de votre carrière
vous à un moment j'ai le niveau de
l'équipe de france c'est ça que je
m'étais dit que je me suis rendu compte
de mon potentiel je lui ai dit pourquoi
pas et toi je me suis comme depuis le
début mais surtout j'ai intensifié
vraiment l'entraînement et j'ai commencé
à rentrer de nouvelles de nouvelles
choses et puis ça a porté ses fruits
alors vous participer ensuite aux
championnats d'europe espoirs était
dernier c'était en 2018 vous devenez
triple champion d'europe en vitesse
individuelle en keirin et en vitesse par
équipes et individuels et individuelles
c'était forcément des championnats us
est franchement réussi à 100% satisfait
étonné même j'ai votre expérience élite
vous a servi peut-être très exactement
ses 101 100 chemin d'europe espoirs à la
pression est moindre et tout de suite le
ressenti du coup bah ouais c'est vrai
c'est l'étincelle étaient toutes là et
tu vois je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi
j'avais j'étais en forme je sais rester
en forme cette période là et derrière
j'ai réussi à concrétiser çà vous aviez
réussi à avoir deux pics de forme dans
la même année les championnats du monde
c'était assez espacées c'était en
février l'autre ans
en août donc avait pas mal de temps pour
bosser mais moi j'ai bien réussi à
élever mon niveau ces deux compétitions
c'est l'un de vos plus beaux souvenirs
ouais je pense je pense elle
actuellement j'ai fait aussi troisième
place à berlin en coupe du monde face à
un très beau souvenir déjà les récents
mais c'est un bon souvenir mais que
champlain d'europe espoirs très bon
souvenir justement cette manche à berne
on va en parler vous êtes troisième de
la vitesse et cette fois-ci vous battez
en huitièmes de finale
jason kenny six médailles d'or aux jeux
olympiques
comment comment réagit après une
victoire comme celle là quand je joue
j'ai pas tremblé je suis resté je reste
moi-même concentré dans mon tournoi
c'était une étape une très belle étape
de passée
finalement quand tu prends du recul
après après tout noir six fois champion
olympique c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
apporté dans le mode sport qui nous
apparaissent encore et c'est une grande
icône sipho championne olympique qui
égale que son compatriote chris hoy donc
lui-même anglais c'est quelque chose de
gros quelque chose de gros et ça fait
toujours plaisir de voir des champions
comme ça parmi nous ça fait des très
beaux matchs et et surtout pour le futur
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
passage de relais une course comme celle
là vous avez 20 ans jason kenny à 30 ans
est ce que vous prenez finalement le pas
sur l'ancienne génération la nouvelle
génération devient plus forte peut-être
que l'ancienne génération symbolisée par
des jason kenny dé grégory baugé par
exemple ou des françois pervis je pense
que ouais c'est un peu ça mais on est
toujours en fait dans ce côté qu'on paie
toi mon avis en fait les anciens encore
beaucoup de bagages pour produire des
belles choses même si sans forcément en
progression et nous les jeunes on
progresse mais il nous manque encore
beaucoup de choses à gérer d'éléments
extérieurs bien préparé ce qu'on a des
sensations contrôler ses émotions toutes
ces choses que les anciens savent faire
que ne savent pas faire du coup ça fait
un peu une balance tu vois on joue avec
ça et puis res et c'est que du positif
est vraiment c'est comme ça c'est chic
de la vie et puis voilà les voilà c'est
celle ci que ces jeunes dans dix ans je
dirais
quand je compte y aura un autre jeune
fille rêve sur et sa queue on se
complète j'en ai un discours à linverse
mais c'est comme ça la vie
ce qui est beau je trouve non sport
comment vous voyez votre avenir
c'est forcément les jo-2020 quatre
médailles d'or il cessa sur cette piste
ici d'entraînement donc que vous
connaissez par coeur
parker on s'entraîne aussi deux fois par
jour donc ce que je souhaite de grandes
boétie à paris chez nous à la maison
donc on se prépare très bien pour ça et
on cultive que l'annoncé avait d'être
champion olympique merci beaucoup
rayonner l'aller on vous souhaite bon
courage pour les jo-2010 24 où on espère
une médaille d'or pour vous merci bien
[Musique]